>> AHMED: Hi, my name is Ahmed. I’m an engineer
on the Android Framework team. I like to show
you a couple of reasons why I just love this
phone. Let’s say, you have a lot of contacts
and you need to find one in a hurry and you
have only one hand free. Instead of taking
in a long time to scroll through all of these,
you can grab the scroll thumb called the “Fast
Scroll” feature, jump down to the letter
of your choice, and then take it from there.
The other feature that I really love when
I’m traveling is—-to a new place, bring
up the maps, choose “My Location” so I
know exactly where I am, and if I want to
get a bird’s-eye-view of the vicinity, I
bring up “Map Mode,” choose “Satellite
View.” I know where I am, I’m supposed
to meet someone at the volleyball court. Hey,
that looks like a sandpit, and I just walk
over to the sandpit, and I find my friend.